un retour en France
entre la Porte de Clichy dans le 17e
arrondissement de la capitale jusqu'à la
place de la Bastille un cortège de gilet
jaune encadré par des effectifs
policiers largement ton surnombre et qui
est arrivé à destination aux environs de
18h alors côté revendications on
retrouve une palette assez large lutte
contre les violences d'État soutien au
DOM-TOM ou je vous le rappelle un
couvre-feu est toujours en vigueur en
Martinique demande de justice sociale et
de démocratie participative ce sont
d'ailleurs les revendications des gilet
jaune depuis les premiers jours il y a
désormais plus de 3 ans
la plupart la majorité des pays
européens lever les mesures sanitaires
c'est le cas de l'Angleterre un petit
peu l'Allemagne le Danemark et cetera
donc c'est dans l'air du temps donc il y
a aucune raison qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
laisse pas l'intégralité des mesures
sanitaires à côté du 15 mars comme
l'annoncer en fait le porte-parole du
gouvernement est-ce que ça va calmer la
grande sociale je ne le pense pas
puisque la grande sociale existe
la pandémie donc elle va elle va
continuer elle va continuer de toute
façon jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle
alors bien sûr à la lutte contre le
passe vaccinal et la vaccination
obligatoire de certaines professions
figures en bonne place des
revendications aujourd'hui et ce alors
que l'épidémie recule dans l'Hexagone et
qu'un relâchement des mesures sanitaires
est attendu dans les semaines ou mois
qui viennent du moins c'est ce qu'on
espère parmi les manifestants rassemblés
ici